WILL BE ANY GOOD.
BUT FOR THE SAKE OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AND KEEPING IT CONTAINED
IN ONE PLACE, IT MIGHT BE A GOOD
THING THAT IT'S COMING, ANYWAY.
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESS ONE MAXINE
WATERS OF CALIFORNIA IS BACK.
NOT THAT SHE WENT ANYWHERE.
SHE RECENTLY GOT INTO A FIGHT ON
THE FLOOR OF THE HOUSE WITH
REPUBLICAN MIKE KELLY.
SHE SAID THAT CAR DEALERS ARE
RACIST.
HERE'S PART OF IT.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT IN 2018,
WE ARE ON THE FLOOR OF CONGRESS
SEEING THE DENIAL OF SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES ABOUT DISCRIMINATION
IN THE AUTO LENDING BUSINESS.
>> TO IMPUGN THE INTEGRITY OF
AUTOMOBILE LENDING PEOPLE IS
BEYOND REPROACH.
>> I AM MORE OFFENDED AS AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN WOMAN AND YOU
WILL EVER BE.
AND THIS BUSINESS ABOUT MAKING
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN, IT IS YOUR
PRESIDENT THAT IS DIVIDING THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: I AM MORE OFFENDED
THAN YOU WILL EVER BE, THEREFORE
I WHEN!
MARK STEIN, AUTHOR AND COLUMNIST
AND ALL-PURPOSE GENIUS JOINS US
TONIGHT, AND LONGTIME
CONNOISSEUR OF THE MAXINE
WATERS.
SO TO ME IT'S FASCINATING NOT
THAT MAXINE WATERS EXISTS, YOU
WANT PEOPLE LIKE THAT AROUND
BECAUSE IT'S HILARIOUS.
BUT THAT SHE HAS SUDDENLY BECOME
ELEVATED TO THE STATUS OF HERO
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL US?
>> IT'S INTERESTING TO ME THAT
SHE IS NOT WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AS SELF-EVIDENTLY
RIDICULOUS AS THE CREEPY PORN
LAWYER THAT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT.
MEGAN DOESN'T KNOW IT, BUT HE
HAS JUST DECIDED TO SWING BY AND
DO IT.
THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT
MAXINE WATERS, IS THAT THIS IS
SOMEONE WHO, FOR EXAMPLE, SHE IS
CLOSE FRIENDS WITH LOUIS
FARRAKHAN, WHO BELIEVES HE HAS
TAKEN UP IN A SPACECRAFT TO
COMMUTE WITH THE GHOST OF ELIJAH
MOHAMMED, AND OTHER ISLAM SPACE
AGENTS ONCE A MONTH.
AND MAYBE HE TAKES MAXINE UP
THERE WITH HIM ONCE A MONTH.
WHICH BY THE WAY, I WOULD BE IN
FAVOR OF THAT.
IF THE SPACE ALIENS ENCOUNTER
MAXINE WATERS AND THINK SHE IS A
TYPICAL EARTHLING, THEY WOULD
HAVE NO PLANS TO COME NEAR THIS
PLANET.
SO THEY WOULD BE PERFORMING A
USEFUL SERVICE IF THEY DID THAT.
IT'S ACTUALLY EXTRAORDINARY TO
ME, THIS.
FOR EXAMPLE, SHE RECENTLY CALLED
THE TRUMP HOTEL IN WASHINGTON A
CRIMINAL LOOKING HOTEL.
THIS IS A WOMAN WHO LIVES IN A
FOREIGN MILLION-DOLLAR HOUSE,
AND IN THAT SENSE, SUMS UP WHAT
KANYE WEST WAS TALKING ABOUT,
THE HOLE, WHAT HAVE YOU GUYS
DONE FOR ME LATELY?
WHAT HAS THE MORTGAGING THE
ENTIRE FUTURE OF ONE DEMOGRAPHIC
GROUP TO THE LIKES OF MAXINE
WATERS ACTUALLY DONE FOR THE
MAN?
THAT IS THE QUESTION THAT I
THINK MORE AND MORE ARE ASKING.
>> Tucker: BUT FOR
GARDEN-VARIETY LIBERALS WHO IN A
NORMAL TIME WOULD HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH MAXINE WATERS' RHETORIC --
SHE JUST GOES TOO FAR.
THEY HAVE WOKEN UP IN THE LAST
YEAR AND DECIDED THAT THEY
REALLY LIKE MAXINE WATERS.
AND SHE SPEAKS FOR THEM.
IS THERE NO ONE ON THE LEFT THAT
SAYS, WAIT A SECOND, SHE'S TOO
CRAZY.
SHE DISCREDITS US.
WHERE ARE THOSE VOICES?
>> >> Mark: THE THING IS, SHE
MADE "TIME" MAGAZINE.
FOR ANYONE WHO WASN'T AWARE,
"TIME" MAGAZINE IS STILL OUT
THERE AND PUBLISHING EVERY WEEK.
SHE MADE THE "TIME" MAGAZINE
LIST OF THE 100 MOST INFLUENTIAL
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD WHICH IS
PATENTLY ABSURD.
"TIME" MAGAZINE AT SOME POINT
USED TO PRETEND TO BE
INTERNATIONAL.
SO THEY PUT THE DEPUTY FISHER AS
MINISTER OF THE SOUTH SANDWICH
ISLANDS ON THE LIST BECAUSE HE'S
REALLY MAKING HIS NAME AS A
PLAYER IN THE SCENE
NEGOTIATIONS.
INSTEAD, THEY PUT MAXINE WATERS
ON THERE, WHO IS TOTALLY
UNINFLUENTIAL, EXCEPT OUTSIDE OF
A VERY TINY ORE COTERIE OF
HARD-CORE ACTIVISTS WHO CHANT
ALONG WITH HER WHEN SHE SAYS,
IMPEACH 45 AS SHE DID RECENTLY
AT A MEMORIAL SERVICE.
YOU KNOW WHEN THEY HAVE THESE
ORGAN DONOR CARDS AND SAYING, IF
I GET KILLED IN A FATAL ROAD
ACCIDENT, GIVE ALL MY PARTY
PARTS TO SOMEONE WHO NEEDS THEM?
I'M GOING TO CARRY A MAXINE
WATERS CARD IN MY WALLET SAYING,
IF I GET KILLED IT, I DON'T WANT
HER CHANTING "IMPEACH 45" AT MY
MEMORIAL SERVICE.
THIS HAS NO APPEAL OTHER THAN
BEYOND A VERY HARD-CORE COTERIE.
BUT THAT COTERIE IS VERY
ESTABLISHED IN THE MEDIA WHICH
IS WHY "TIME" MAGAZINE MADE
THEMSELVES LOOK FOOLS BY PUTTING
HER ON THIS VERY INFLUENTIAL 100